[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lavelle
we are told the doj's capital riot
investigation is one of the largest
in american history the fbi has made it
clear it will not leave one stone
unturned
seeking to prosecute what it calls
domestic terrorists
all of us want answers surrounding this
horrific event
but is this also a purging of trump
loyalists
[Music]
cross talking the capital riot i'm
joined by my guest william beanie in
baltimore he's a former intelligence
officer with the nsa
in raleigh we have ray mcgovern he is a
former cia analyst
and in ossining we cross to don dubar he
is the senior producer
at cpr news all right gentlemen
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want
and i always appreciate it william let
me go to you first i was going to the
pages of the american conservative and
this article
by james bovard came up will fbi
chats send conservatives to prison i
think that is probably the most direct
way
of starting out this program because it
looks exactly like that to me
considering it's been months now since
the riot on capitol hill
we have preciously little information
and we have the head of the fbi
seemingly to go out of his way to please
congress
in their hearings about those horrific
events so
what about this title will the fbi chats
send conservatives to prison your
thoughts go ahead
i think they will attempt to do anything
they can to uh
to discredit anybody involved in the
trump campaign and the trump supporters
and i think that's their objective
they've been trying to label all the
all the uh trump trump people all 75
million of them
as terrorists and and that's the way
that that's the way out that's why they
had that
section 1021 input into the um
the uh the authorization act for the
military authorization act uh
back in 2012. that was one that
basically stated uh
the the same thing that a special order
48 did with the nazis issued in 1933
that said
you know the they had the authority to
imprison anybody with the military
and do that and keep them indefinitely
with no due process whatsoever
that's exactly what exactly what special
order 48 was and eventually they used
the
nazis used that to get rid of all their
political enemies and anybody else they
didn't like and that's what's really
looking like it's going to happen here
ray why is this
investigation taking so long the fbi
the doj have asked for more time it
sounds like they're trying to
can looking for more dots to connect
because
they don't have enough dots now to make
their case so they need to keep the
they have a much larger dragnet as it
were
that's what it appears to me because
they're they're they're react their
answers to questions why you need more
time don't make any sense to me so i'm
going to have to
come up with my own suppositions go
ahead bray your thoughts
well peter the fbi is unrestrained
it's unsupervised it has a record of
deceiving the american people
mostly for the last four or five years
for the current
phase and you know when you get people
like senator grassley
of the judiciary committee in the senate
who is supposed to be
overseeing the fbi and the department of
justice
um when he comes out in a tweet
no less and says well
it's the department of just us
now i don't know if he got that from
bill benny but bill benny's been saying
that for three years or more okay
the department of just us and what did
grassley mean
he meant simply that with the fbi
violating the law
kleinsmith the lawyer
fabricating uh information to justify
a foreign intelligence court warrant
uh and comey lying
saying that the steel document the steel
dossier so to speak was verified that's
what he told the judge
on the same day he told the national
intelligence director
no no still still stuff has was not
never been we can't corroborate it same
day
we have written documents for two so
what i'm saying here
is that if you need further proof that
the fbi
is unsupervised and can do whatever it
wants
here's the he's now ranking chair of the
judiciary committee
in the senate used to be the chairman
and he said well looks like the
department of justice is really the
department of
just us and i'm reminded of that
wonderful uh
dizzy were where they say you know um
it's a big club i just realized that
you're not in it that's exactly right
you know john
this also this investigation into the
riot on the capitol on january 6
this is expanded into the military i i
find if someone would have told me a few
months ago
that they'd be purging the military for
suspicious thoughts bad
thoughts okay um and obviously it only
goes in one direction here
i mean this this is a um a drag net as
it were here and it seems to be
all all branches of government are
pursuing it here
and and just to go back to to uh what
bill had to say
because about 75 million people voted
the wrong way
is this how we should interpret it go
ahead don
first of all the thing that enables this
the event quote unquote you know the
insurrection
whatever term that someone wants to
throw against the wall
to see what sticks what we're talking
about is a couple of hundred people
that went through the capitol building
without authorization
was the capitol building when the joint
session apparently was guarded
uh less effectively than say the
football field at the super bowl for
sure
in terms of security because the fan 60
000 people could never overrun or have
it never overrun that yet
and they're really except for the one
police officer and the woman that got
shot in the face
or the head or whatever murdered by the
police
no one was killed they didn't burn the
building down there you know they
walked off with the you know odais and
they made a mess out of the place
for that the trillion-dollar military
that's right the god knows how much
money we spend on intelligence agencies
and the fbi which i wouldn't include in
that
all of them are being you know turned
inside out and re-exempt it reminds me
of
my concerns about our air defenses that
were supposed to protect us against an
attack by the soviet union for 50 years
that suddenly were you know easily
penetrated by a handful of knuckleheads
from the middle east
and a couple of jetliners and and yet
they wanted to
again just as in you know with the
patriot act in
september of 2001 you know they want to
do away with everyone's
civil rights and human rights over this
and just one last thing
for the people on the left and liberals
who aren't there but
uh who think that this is okay because
it's being done to quote-unquote
trumpers
take a look at the cohento pro papers
take a look at the records from the
citizens committee
50 years ago last week that broke into
the fbi's office in pennsylvania
what they found was out of 50 some odd
percent of the cases
that they handled at all at their budget
most were handled
were against political targets and only
two or three percent were against the
right most of them are against the left
and it will be that way
here also if you allow it to happen to
anyone
you know bill explain to us you have a
long career in this here
i simply can't get my head around the
fact that
how many countless billions of dollars
are spent on surveillance on
intelligence on gathering information
how could this get how could this
possibly happen on the nation's
capital i mean it doesn't make any sense
i mean you know they're guarding
buildings all around the world but they
couldn't guard that one
and can you do you have an answer to
that because again
they they won't they won't give us a
straight answer on what happened
for something of its magnitude they're
remarkably quiet except for the number
of investigations that they're
pursuing and the number of people that
are in custody and the number that could
be
go ahead bill well it's pretty to me it
seems pretty simple
they had some evidence that this was
being prepared in advance and they knew
about it in advance
and yet they did nothing to beef up
security or anything just be able to
deal with it as it happened so it meant
to me very simply put that they wanted
it to happen
why because that would allow them then
to discredit the entire trump campaign
and and uh and start to move to try to
classify them as terrorists and that's
exactly what they've been doing
and yet most of them just went through
the white white uh the
capitol building taking pictures like
taurus yeah you know the ones
the ones who were doing it were very few
in number and they were the ones leading
the packing citing the
people to do other things and that when
you get people together in mass like
that sometimes that's an easy thing to
get some people to do
and that's fine that fundamentally was
their plan that's right
right right weigh in on that because i
think that's very important because
as it was just pointed out i mean they
were taking pictures to put on instagram
and facebook i mean
what kind of criminal element or or
criminal intent
does that i mean bill just hit the nail
on the head there i mean this look
it looked like a lot of tourists and
then it got out of hand a small number
of people
turned it into a riot but even as you
know i mean they had a guy that looked
like chewbacca i mean
it was this to fake us all out or
something go ahead ray
well you know i think we have to get out
of out from the trees and look at the
forest here
um why was this allowed to happen
uh who's who was in charge
uh it was the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi and that fellow from
kentucky
the leader in the senate they're the
ones
in charge of the capitol police
and they didn't do anything so we have
to start looking there
now what is nancy pelosi saying now well
she's
talking to hillary clinton
and she's saying my god we have to have
a 9 11 investigation
clinton's suggestion clinton says i'd
love to see
uh what poutine was telling trump on
the sixth of january okay
now you laugh i laugh even the new york
times has laughed at that
i think that's the only russian thing
that they didn't play but think about
the implications here
let's just add this oliver stone was a
friend of mine
told me that during one recent session
with vladimir putin
pooching exasperated threw up his hands
and he says you know the russians are
being treated just like the jews were
in the 30s before world war ii end quote
whoa what does that mean that means
they're being scapegoated they've been
blamed for everything
and what's the implication of that well
if nancy pelosi
and hillary clinton are still running
the democratic party that's right
when it all comes to push comes to shove
this spring when there are
demonstrations in the street
who's going to be blamed for that well
it's let's begin with the hand
of lesbian pooching because all roads
lead to pooching
all right you're going to have a major
part all right ray let me jump in here
gentlemen we're going to go to a hard
break and after that hard break we'll
continue our discussion on the capitol
hill right stay
with rt
[Music]
okay let's go let's go back to don here
you know don one of the things i find
very
distressing even disgusting is that if
you lie to the fbi
and and and that can include casual
yeses and casual no's
um you can face a prison term but the
fbi can
lie to you all right in building their
case and
unlike what they're being portrayed in
the media a lot of these trump
supporters are the most vulnerable in
society they make them into monsters
but these are a lot of these people are
are poor working
people and no and and many of them are
not very well educated because the
american educational system is awful
um and so you have the full power of the
state one of the largest investigations
in the country
and christopher way wants to you know
serve up something to congress and the
media
but you know if you if you have a if you
don't answer in the way they want it
like for example
were you near the capitol well in their
mind near can mean something and the
person that's being asked
can mean something else ben and they can
say no that's not true
you lied to the fbi you're on their hit
list okay
i mean it seems to me the fbi is that
they're just showing
um their the veil has dropped they're
showing really who they are
well first of all i mean that's pretty
much what happened to to flynn today
general flint yeah in other words if
you're a senior official you're not
invulnerable and uh and they use this
you know they weaponize uh their
investigative tools
to be able it's not uh prosecution in
the strict sense of it but rather
in the broad sense of it almost to the
to the level or even to the level
of persecution they they have weapons
that they can use
to take out their political allies they
they can retrofit basically onto some
statute
to justify criminalizing behavior that
is
really not criminal behavior you know
people were warning of this kind of
thing when the rico statutes were
passed and things like that but
practically speaking the everyday
business of the fbi
uses these tools constantly against
people
and and one of the problems that you
know you have to take a look at this
again in historical context
first of all the american public have
been thoroughly brainwashed about the
fbi
um you know you look at the the
untouchables to
the fbi uh time television these are the
you know the most upright
the best educated untouchable literally
uh you know public officials in the
business the
you know they cannot be corrupted and
yet it's the most corrupt institution
perhaps
on the planet when you consider the
reach that uh
their corrupt behavior has and it to
where now you're looking at
in essence the fbi has established
itself
or some people with control over the fbi
have used the fbi
to establish themselves as a power unto
itself
even over the government i mean what
what i think we
have seen with this episode
was a direct intervention by the fbi in
the outcome of the 2020 election
one of many that led to the outcome that
that we have seen
and what they're doing now is clean up
work and preventative maintenance going
forward
where anyone who might first of all
prove that there was
wrongdoing with respect to the election
in 2020
and and and secondly look to prevent
that from happening in the future will
be taken out as political entities
by criminalizing them you know you know
let me go to bill here
that's exactly where i wanted to go
because it seems to me that
we're going down the path of
criminalizing dissent
and criminalizing having your own
opinion be
and also with this you know if we look
at hr1
we look at this investigation uh we look
at all of the shenanigans
associated with the russia gate hoax it
seems to me and
i'm going to make a big statement here
but i think we're going in the direction
of
disenfranchising tens of millions of
people
you what do you say bill go ahead well
it's not just i don't think it's just
that peter but
it's also uh like i referred back to
nazi special order 48 that's the kind of
thing they want to bring online and
start
using and i see this coming very very
clearly from what they've been doing
you know it's not just it's not just
targeting people for
for just to get them out of the way or
silence them or anything it's also
you know doing other things like using i
mean i'm
quite cl confident that the fbi is
involved just like they were in
cointelpro against silencing
any kind of dissent internally in this
country and using any means they have
available
and that includes things like directed
energy weapons we here are
in my house are also picking up this
from uh from using uh
spectrum analyzes things of that we are
detecting these kinds of things being
directed at us
so this is nothing new and i'm i'm uh
these people
have not stopped at anything they'll lie
in the court of law they
they fabricated evidence against us uh
whistleblowers from nsa
and and made up just outright lies about
us just
and got the court to buy into it because
what does the court know
they don't know anything except what the
government tells them they have no way
of verifying or validating anything
they're being told
and they've known for years and decades
in fact that the fbi's lied to them
consistently
and yet they do nothing about it why
because they're a part of it
and even even uh we heard reports over
here that judge roberts was telling the
rest of the members of the supreme court
not to hear the
the uh texas and other state complaints
against the
disenfranchising the votes during the
doing that by by having uh
pennsylvania and the other states uh
stuffed ballots into the box and
and uh violate their their even violate
their constitutions internally in the
states on
in terms of how to handle votes so i'm
in it the courts are involved in this
i mean all parts of our government are
corrupt now they're all in
a part of it and each has to cover up
for the other or they all fall
you know you know ray i i guess the the
the
the lightning i was going to say the
silver lining but it's not a silver
lining it's just the opposite
is that we have big tech i don't i want
to continue with my question that i had
for bill there i mean
disenfranchising people because with big
tech now
i mean almost all of us in one way or
another live through these different
platforms and all that
and and so i mean if you're on the wrong
side of the divide and the fbi says so
and the courts won't
intervene then they just disappear you
you're just
gone okay i mean and i i that that's
we've already seen
um uh individuals and groups of people
being marginalized and disappeared
already and now that with the in grand
investigation
the most extensive in american history
will be definitive
and they'll that will be the trigger
that they will pull and then
then we see a good part of civil society
disappear
your thoughts ray well it's very clear
that the fbi
is riding high okay so is the whole
national security state including the
cia nsa and the others
they've won a big a big deal here no
longer being investigated
i think that john durham the famous john
dorm investigation
is is over in other words the fbi will
not never be held accountable
i'm not sure exactly what merrick
garland is going to do as attorney
general but the signs tell me
that he'd just sweep it under the rug
and the fbi
who demonstrably lied now i'll give you
his
more recent example comey we know
told the fisa court foreign intelligence
surveillance act
court on 12th of january 2017
the steele dossier was verified yep
on the same day we have the email he
sent
to the director of national intelligence
james clapper in which he said we cannot
we cannot work hard real hard but we
cannot corroborate what steel says
in his dossier well both of those things
cannot be correct and we know which one
is correct since the dossier has been
completely discredited so call me
lied to the court that's a felony and
he's going to get away with it
now that's that's the the core of the
question here because
if john durham is just allowed to go out
to pasture
even despite his uh his visage from
central casting you know that one one
picture he's a hard guy well
he's a hard guy right but when he's told
to knock it off he knocks it off as has
been proved two times in the past with
respect to cia torture
uh it's going to go away and then you
talk about power
the fbi and cia will be totally
empowered to do whatever they want
okay one more thing as uh
as bob mueller uh left the fbi he made a
big speech before a bunch of
intelligence people including retirement
people like me
and uh i had a chance to ask him a
course question i said mr mr mueller
do you have any legal qualms uh with the
the notion of a parallel construction
where you
illegally collect some with the help of
nsa
and then you use that with the local
police to say look this is information
you can use to catch this guy
don't tell anybody where you got to go
tell the judge don't tell the defense
don't tell anybody
and you can get them do you have any
problem legal problems with that you
know what he said
he says mr mcgovern uh uh after 9 11
uh we were we had been given special
authorities
well give me a break special authorities
as far as i know the fourth amendment of
our constitution
still exists you can't have special
authorities to violate that
but that's what they use as bill knows
better than i
and they're riding high right now and
they're very much in in league with the
people
uh who invented all the structure gate
stuff and biden
unfortunately was one of those you know
don do you
it seems to me that they're going to use
this the the findings of this uh
investigation
which will um who knows could turn into
some kind of show trial they're going to
put all of these defendants on trial in
a stadium or something like that
because what they what they want to do
the direction they're going into
they need a trial like that a such a
media event
to legitimize the national security
state control over everything
and you have big tech as i said earlier
they'll be have their back right there
and it'll be mission accomplished they
would have because they did they never
want 2016 to happen
again and that is not a defense of
donald trump coming from me
at all what i'm talking about is that
they will make sure the system will work
the way
they want it to because they the system
failed
them it didn't fail the people it failed
the people in power go ahead don
i have to remember something at the very
beginning here we're talking about
the national police force
essentially having all power accrued to
it or
run through it that is a per se
definition of a police state
and given the scope and magnitude of the
american state
both on the u.s territory and around the
world
it is the largest and scariest police
state
that has ever existed in human history
this is the context for the conversation
that we're having now
while we're discussing this great leap
forward
in acquiring additional power out of the
people that have been arrested already
in washington the hundreds
i'm gonna guess the same game that they
play with any criminal prosecution is a
foot
they're scaring the hell out of most of
the people who are
innocent of everything to get them to
plead out
and testify against the people okay okay
gentlemen we've run out of time it looks
like we're gonna have a police state
we'll
have a smiley on it here many thanks to
my guests in baltimore raleigh and us
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at rt see you next time and
remember
crosstalk rules